ختامنا اليوم ابيض كالثلج وتقلوبنا رداء
ابيض يكسو جبال الاطلس في الجزائر بعيدا
عن ضجيج المدينه حول المكان لمتنزه
للراغبين في السجن الاستجمام هو الاستمتاع
بجمال الطبيعه هناك ظاهره نادره اثار
الدهشه وفرحه الجميع الكثبان رمليه
الصفراء اكتست بالبياض في صحراء الجزائر
بعد سنوات من الجفاف ونظره تساقط الثلوج
ليس فقط مرتفعات الاطلس والشريعه بل شهدت
العديد من المدن الجزائريه تساقطا كبيرا
للثلوج في اجواء استثنائيه وغير مسبوقه
منذ نحو عشر سنوات ولا تزال اكثر من 20
محافظه جزائريه تعيش اجواء شديده البروده
معا انخفاض درجه الحراره الى عشر درجات
تحت الصفر
[موسيقى]
منتشره بشكل كبير تظهر تدخل اللون الذهبي
للرمال الصحراء مع لون الثلج الابيض في
الصحراء الجزائريه وتحديدا في بلده عين
الصفراء الواقعه غرب الجزائر في سلسله
جبال الاطلس في الصحراء الكبرى
[موسيقى]
ونادين هذه المره الرابعه منذ 42 سنه
تتساقط الثلوج على قمم الكثبان الرمليه في
الصحراء الجزائر المره الرابعه في 42 سنه
يعني هذا التناقض صحراء مع ثلج يعني بيعمل
لوحه فنيه جميله جدا يعني الجزائر ازدادت
جمالا معها الثلج
جميل بوجودك